As a quick refresher,
we've been working with example
survey data that has missing values.
One way to deal with these missing
values is just to eliminate
any observations that have missing data.
But because of the negatives related
to that, we might want to keep all of
the observations and just try to
fill in the blanks, so to speak.
The important thing here is
to provide the fake data so
that our model can get closer
to what's actually true.
One common method is to replace
the missing values with a predefined
statistic, the mean, median, or mode.
As a reminder to all of us,
the mean is the average of the values.
Technically, it's where we add
up all the existing values and
divide them by the number
of values you have.
The median is the midpoint
in the data values.
To determine this, you basically
put all the values in order, and
than select the value that's halfway
between the first and the last values.
The mode is the most
common of the data values.
In other words, it's value that
occurs most often in the data set.
If you remember, in one of our
previous segments we showed what
the real ages were for
respondents number 3 and number 9.
I've gone ahead and
added in the rest of the real data for
the purpose of our example.
If you recall in that segment,
the average, or mean,
age for the known respondents was 40.
If we impute 40 for all the missing age
values and impute the average income for
each of the missing income values,
which in this case is 60,000,
we can then see the effect that it
has in comparison to using the delete
method for
dealing with the missing data.
Here we see a scatter
plot of the real data.
The slope of the line would indicate,
in general, that as age increases so
does income.
But if we look at the scatter plot where
we just delete records that have missing
data, we can see that this
scatter plot of the leftover data
actually has the scope of the line
going in the wrong direction,
indicating that as age
increases income goes down.
And when we add in a scatter plot of
the imputed data using the averages of
the existing data, we find that,
though it may not be quite accurate,
it at least gets us going in the right
direction, as to the slope of the line.
The imputed data model isn't perfect,
but
it does seem to get us closer
in this specific case.
Let's put we've we learn
together in the form of a quiz.